united with her mother who had made the
arduous journey to escape the war in
ukraine
the joy of reunion is laced with anger
but also
people come here weary and vulnerable
and it is relentless
every few minutes another bus comes
along and this is what the passengers
see as they arrive offers of help
transport and food
it is a big collective effort the
firefighters are organizing things
driving buses offering assistance
and then there are the volunteers
frank drove all the way from the czech
republic a country where mistrust of
russia still runs deep
if i think where the russians and
russians are horrible we have the same
experience with them from era of
communism so
we feel with them yeah and
we want to help them
and help will be crucial the number of
people fleeing ukraine is rising all the
time
well as these people arrive here they
are met by offers of comfort and
support it's a sort of veneer of
happiness but the reality is these
coaches are full of women and children
and pensioners who are fleeing their
country and as the weather here gets
tougher
this has the potential to move from
being an exodus of people
to an absolute refugee crisis
the cue to reach this border is enormous
imagine sitting in your car in a war
zone for days
simply to get away from your own country
we went by car like three
uh three days
and we stepped in the car
because we couldn't find the
place where to sleep
so we slept in the car
these images do stick with you the
innocence of youth displaced by the
horror of war
adam parsons sky news on the poland
ukraine border